pour le 78 lectu sur TVfil 78 nous
allons faire le tour de l'actualité
locale sans plus attendre voici les
principaux titres de ce soir ouverture
des rencontres de l'autonomie à 50 ans
en eveling 3 jours de débats et
d'échanges avec les professionnels de la
santé alors qu'une concertation sur la
mise en place d'une loi dans ce domaine
vient de débuter en France aujourd'hui 3
décembre Journée internationale des
personnes en situation de handicap nous
le verrons dans un instant avec les
invités de ce journal qui témoigneront
notamment de leur quotidien et puis le
luxe pour tous des prixas sur de grandes
marques le Paris de one nation le
nouveau centre commercial des clés
sous-bois qui ouvre demain visite guidée
à suivre le 3 décembre Journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
un rendez-vous fixé par l'ONU qui permit
depuis 1980
de mieux faire comprendre les problèmes
liés au handicap et sensibiliser le
public au bénéfice de l'insertion des
personnes handicapées dans tous les
aspects de la vie économique sociale et
culturelle je reçois sur ce plateau
Florence sirogoio bonsoir vous êtes
vice-présidente de Capsa c'est sport av
art aventure et amitié que je n'oublie
pas un des trois a vous êtes quatre fois
médaillé aux Jeux paralympiqu également
merci d'être présente sur ce plateau et
puis Maria letao bonsoir vous êtes
administratrice pour Capsa on va tout
d'abord débuter par vos sentiments vos
ressentis respectifs sur cette situation
du handicap aujourd'hui puisque le but
c'est de changer les le regard la
perception du grand public est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que les choses
évoluent est-ce que la société le regard
de la société évolue sur les personnes
en situation de handicap alors la
société
euh euh évolue moi ça fait plus de 30
ans que je suis tétraplégique donc j'ai
une certaine expérience euh depuis l'âge
de 15 ans ça évolue sûrement mais
doucement quand
même il reste encore beaucoup de choses
à faire mais en tout cas cette journée
c'est l'occasion justement de parler du
handicap de le rendre encore plus
visible grâce aux médias et grâce à
notre présence ici et merci de nous
avoir invité merci surtout à vous d'être
venu Maria vous partagez cet avis la
société ça change ça évolue ça change
tout doucement mais ça change mais mais
mieux vaut que ça aille doucement
et que ça mais s mais sûrement si ça va
trop vite et puis après qu'on revienne à
l'arrière c'est pas la peine et merci de
nous avoir invité parce que c'est très
important pour nous alors là on évoquit
vos ressentis respectifs sur la
situation aujourd'hui si on prend
d'exemples concrets en revanche sur le
quotidien est-ce qu'il est difficile par
exemple pour vous en fauteuil au
quotidien d'accéder au magasin de vous
déplacer dans les transport on arrive
sur des périodes de fêt de fin d'année
les gens sortent vont faire leur cours
et se posent pas la question quand on
est en fauteuil c'est un peu plus
différent un peu plus compliqué alors
c'est différent alors il se trouve que
moi j'habite dans le centreville du
Montini ça a été un choix puisque c'est
un des sites les plus accessibles quand
même vous avez réglé justement votre vie
votre quotidien votre lieu de résidence
enou organiser ma vie en fonction de ma
situation de handicap pour la rendre
plus plus accessible plus facile et
moins
contraignante et moins frustrante aussi
les transports en commun restent
toutefois difficile d'accès donc moi
j'ai la possibilité de pouvoir conduire
donc c'est une chance mais je connais
d'autres d'autres amis qui qui ne le
peuvent pas et c'est parfois compliqué
même si certaines lignes le sont Maria
letao je précise que vous êtes
malvoyante vous êtes accompagné de votre
chien d'aveugle qu'on ne voit pas qui
est très sagement assis à vos pieds qu
quelles sont vos difficultés au
quotidien est-ce qu'il en subsiste
encore aujourd'hui oui énormément parce
que quand quand je prends je prends
régulièrement le bus h et ce qu'il a bon
ils ont la synthèse vocale mais que
souvent ils la mettent pas alors bon on
sait pas où est-ce qu'on est donc alors
il faut demander au chauffeur qui nous
dit et s nous oublie que ça m'est déjà
arrivé qui m'oublie al de me dire l'arrê
buus ce que c'était bon c'était on va
plus loin mais après on fait demi-tour
alors ça serait bien qu'il metettent la
synthèse vocale qui est la synthèse
vocal h cap ça cap sport art aventure et
amitié on va parler plus précisément des
actions que vous menez auparavant un
micro trottoir comme chaque soir vous
réagissez à l'actualité nous sommes
aujourd'hui allez vous n demander tout
simplement comment mettre fin à
l'exclusion des personnes en situation
de handicap quelle solution
préconisez-vous vos réponses en essayant
de se mettre à leur place par exemple en
essayant de se mettre dans un fauteuil
roulant pour voir l'effet que ça fait et
puis tous les inconvénients qu' trouvent
sur le route puisque en fait les villes
ne sont pas toutes appropriées à leur
handicap comme on était contre
l'exclusion des handicapés donc c'est un
travail du fond donc il faut voir ça par
rapport au gouvernement et ben il faut
se mettre à leur service d'aménager des
zones
aménager les espaces pour eux et puis
être à leur écoute disons en aménageant
des des espaces pour eux des serce que
au niveau de les infrastructures parce
qu'il y a pas il y a pas grand-chose de
fait il y en a il y en a un petit peu il
y a une volonté quand même de faire
quelque chose mais pour l'instant il y a
encore des des améliorations à appter
hein aussi bienaccès au magasins aussi
bien après les au niveau des des
soutiens pour les gens quoi des structur
qui est et pour pour aider les familles
qui sont dans en difficulté avec ces
problèmes là quoi l'accessibilité ce qui
revient dans le micro trottoir ce qu'on
a pu entendre et puis également intégrer
les les personnes en situation
d'handicap pourquoi pas par le sport
c'est aussi ce que vous faites avec
votre association peut peut-être
préciser le le champ d'action de Capsa h
HM alors on propose des activités
sportives ludiques à travers la
natatation à travers la musculation
l'équitation
euh les jeux de ballons le multisport le
multisport euh et l'école de et l'école
des sport pour les enfants à partir de 6
ans alors l'école des sports c'est un
partenariat avec la Ville d'élancour euh
et c'est une une des première en tout
cas euh qui permet l'intégration des
enfants en situation de handicap avec
les enfants dit ordinaire valide hein
tout ça encadré c'est pas un club
spécifique non là c'est pas un club
spécifique rouve oui tout à fait et ça
c'est une grande richesse bah pour tous
euh voilà ou à savoir quand même qu'il y
a le notre prof de sport qui est présent
avec les enfants handicapés pour les
aider pour intervenir également est-ce
que monter une structure justement
accueillir là on parlait des enfants en
situation de handicap ça coûte aussi
plus cher c'est une des difficultés que
peuvent rencontrer les clubs parce que
s'équiper c'est pas la même chose aussi
ça coûte plus cher oui ou non alors
c'est une idée reçue non c'est pas une
idée ça dépend aussi des activités qui
sont proposées euh mais ça n'empêche que
voilà il nous faut un éducateur sportif
hein comme dans toutes les associations
sportives certes mais bah c'est
difficile d'avoir les budgets donc
surtout depuis plusieurs années hein les
budgets sont de plus en plus réduits
donc ce qui nous fait faire aussi des
sensibilisations au sein des écoles
primaires des entreprises euh h des
communes aussi justement parce que ça
nous permet de récolter des fonds pour
pouvoir que l'association vive en
complément quand même de certaines
subventions des villes et d'ailleurs
sans certaines villes de de de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
l'association ne pourrait pas proposer
ces activités mais vous qui êtes sportif
de haut niveau avec ces
différentes participation pardon aux
Jeux paralympiques par le par le passé
vous avez ressenti comment les les
choses a été difficile pour vous de
d'atteindre ce
niveau ça a été difficile parce que les
infrastructures accueillant les
personnes sportives en situation de
handicap il y en avait il y en a pas
beaucoup donc j'ai fait beaucoup
beaucoup de kilomètres euh parce que moi
j'ai d'abord débuté par l'athlétisme et
là peu de club un matériel spécifique
onéreux contrairement au tennis de table
que je pratique aujourd'hui voilà et
puis je pratique à en cours où une
section handisport a été créée depuis 3
saisons on va poursuivre cet entretien
parler du handicap en cette journée un
peu particulière avec à présent une
semaine du handicap organisée au château
de Versailles par la Fondation Française
des jeux l'événement qui propose des
visite gratuite notamment pour les
personnes en situation de handicap des
séries de conférences d'atelierers vont
aussi se tenir d'ici à vendredi lundi
nous avons suivi une des associations
qui participai à ces visites le
reportage de yolen
Torz la galerie de bataille j'adorais
c'était vraiment très sympa et la
galerie des Glaces bien sûr puis les
appartements enfin ouis non c'est c'est
vraiment super quoi loin de la foule
habituelle ils étaient quelques
privilégiés ce lundi à bénéficier d'une
visite privée du château de Versailles
eux ce sont les membres de l'association
comme les autres et Capsa une
soixantaine de personnes en situation de
handicap ont alors découvert tous les
secret du château moi par exemple je
suis déjà venu deux fois au château mais
j'ai jamais eu cette opportunité aussi
aussi proche en tout cas de cette
réalité du de la vie du du château et
c'est vrai que c'est vraiment un bonheur
énorme un
privilège je pense qu'on saavoure à
grand plaisir un plaisir accentué par le
fait de pouvoir déambuler tranquillement
dans le château normalement fermé le
lundi aux visiteurs là le fait d'avoir
le champ libre ça permet à chacun de
pouvoir s'approcher des œuvres de
pouvoir mieux entendre les explications
du guide donc c'est un vrai un vrai
accès privilégié à la culture et un
moment de réel bien-être ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas quand il se
retrouve au milieu d'un main de foule
jusqu'à dimanche toute personne en
situation de handicap pourra visiter le
château gratuitement sur simple
inscription par mail visite conférence
rencontres ou encore projection de film
sont au programme quelques 500 personnes
sont attendues sur l'ensemble de la
semaine notre ambition est de montrer
que ce château qui d'un premier abord
n'est pas forcément accessible à tous
est en fait ouvert à tout le
monde notre ambition est également de
montrer les efforts qui sont faits pour
accueillir le plus grand monde et pour
s'ouvrir à toute forme de
handicap et pour s'engager encore un peu
plus en faveur de ce public particulier
ce lundi le château a mis en place une
nouvelle maquette tactile un moyen
d'appréhender le château de manière
beaucoup plus simple et accessible aussi
aux personnes en situation de handicap
en attendant il reste quelques places
pour cette semaine il faudra choisir
entre la conférence gustative samedi ou
la projection du film Les adieux à
l'arène ce
dimanche deux invités en plateau donc
pour parler de cette journée du 3
décembre Journée internationale des
personnes en situation de de handicap on
a vu cette opération organisée au
château de Versailles est-ce que c'est
une bonne illustration de ce qu'il faut
faire organiser des visites
spécifiques alors pour parce que là ça
mêle pas tout le monde ce sont des
journées spécifiques pour ces personnes
en situation de handicap ce sont des
journées spécifiques mais je sais que
voilà si on y va n'importe quel autre
jour on sera tout aussi bien accueilli
voà et là au ça permet de mettre
l'accent et de de montrer ou ouis ça
permet en tout cas de savoir que ça
existe grâce à ces journées spécifiques
et c'est ça aussi qui est important on
parlait juste avant ce reportage de vos
activités de Capsa quels sont les on
parlait des domaines d'intervention mais
les activités concrètes que vous
proposez et puis pour qui aussi parce
que pendant le reportage vous me le
disiez on ne s'adresse pas qu'aux
personnes en situation de handicap déjà
c'est tous les handicaps et puis c'est
aussi ouvert à tous Voilà c'est ouvert à
tous tout handicap et il y a les
personnes valides qui peuvent venir
aussi al quelles sont les activités
spécifiques qui sont proposées il y a la
natation il y a le il y a la il y a la
musculation h savoir qu'il y a un prof
qui est avec nous alors c'est bien parce
que il y a le le multisport et il y a
l'équitation voilà c'est puis a l'école
des sports pour les enfants qui c'est
super ça et puis il y a des rencontres à
l'occasion de l'année ce qui permet de
de de voir les autres adhérents qu'on n'
pas l'habitude de voir dans les autres
activités donc c'est une association qui
permet de créer du lien aussi entre nous
euh avec entre personnes en situation de
handicap leur famille et les amis donc
c'est vraiment une mixité qui est le
reflet de la société c'est vivre tous
ensemble avec nos différences et euh et
puis l'association aussi permet de
rompre l'isolement pour certains et et
de de favoriser la solidarité merci à
toi toutes les deux ce sera la
conclusion une jolie conclusion merci à
vous d'être venu nous parler de ces
situations de handicap et puis du
message que vous souhaitez faire passer
en cette mixité cette importance de de
se retrouver ensemble lors de cette
journée et pas seulement tout au long de
l'année bien sûr merci encore à vous
merci 3è édition des Rencontres de
l'autonomie qui ont démarré ce matin
avec plus d'un million de bénéficiaires
de laallocation personnalisée
d'autonomie au 31 décembre 2012 le sujet
représente un enjeu majeur pour le
gouvernement le conseiller de la
ministre déléguée chargée des personnes
âgées et de l'autonomie s'est déplacé
sur les lieux du lancement de cette
opération c'était ce matin à la Faculté
des sciences de la santé à l'université
de Versailles 5tin en evveline yolen
Torz Patrick Jacques de dixmud la 3e
édition des Rencontres de l'autonomie a
démarré ce matin Michel delonet ministre
délégué chargé des personnes âgées et de
l'autonomie a finalement été représenté
par son conseiller rodolp du moulin
l'occasion pour lui d'annoncer les
grandes lignes du projet de loi du
gouvernement dans le domaine la
concertation a été lancée C vendredi
dernier le plan devrait entrer en
vigueur en 2015 d'après les chiffres du
gouvernement les plus de 60 ans
représentent aujourd'hui à peu près 25 %
de la population demain il serait près
d'un tiers c'est un projet qui intégrera
la réforme de la dépendance celle qui
avait été tant de fois promise et
reportée c'est-à-dire la réforme de l'
personnalisée
autonomie mais aussi un volet prévention
de la perte d'autonomie qui cherchera à
identifier comment on peut mieux
anticiper les pertes d'autonomie car on
y peut quelque chose notamment par les
aides techniques par les actions de
prévention et puis un volet adaptation
de la société vieillissement les
rencontres de l'autonomie continuent
jusqu'à jeudi pour ce dernier jour des
ateliers grand public seront proposés
sur le site de gérondicap à Manamo ils
évoqueront la protection juridique la
loi Leonetti et le
bien-être le Conseil de développement de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline le codesski qui
se prononce sur la place de
l'agglomération dans le Grand Paris le
codeskii une assemblé constitué
uniquement de citoyens ils sont 85 à
travailler sur les questions de santé
d'habitat ou plus globalement
d'aménagement du territoire son AVI est
consultatif devant les élus locaux
c'était en fin de semaine dernière ils
ont expliqué que le schéma directeur de
la région Île-de-France privilégié trop
Versailles notamment en matière de
transport cela pourrait être pénalisant
pour le développement économique pour
autant le Grand Paris est bel et bien un
atout
50 ans evveline fait clairement partie à
tout à gagné à ce projet à condition
justement de de ne pas se trouver un
petit peu isolé mais sinon très
clairement il y a déjà une dynamique il
y a déjà des entreprises il y a des
atouts euh
50 anine est bien situé géographiquement
par rapport au Grand Paris certes
peut-être un peu loin de Paris mais
justement sur l'axe vers la Normandie
dans dans un département qui par
ailleurs a beaucoup d'atout euh donc non
50 ans niline a vraiment tout à gagner
dans le Grand Paris nous on peut pas se
mettre aller jusqu'à donner des conseils
sur la manière de procéder au aux élus
hein après euh nous espérons que les
avis du codé ski peuvent les aider aussi
à argumenter c'est-à-dire typiquement
comme il y a des données euh que le
message est démontré euh nous espérons
qu'ils pourront utiliser aussi ces
argumentations euh l lors de des
rencontres qu'ils peuvent avoir au
sommet ce mercredi le plus grand
complexe français de magasins d'usine de
lux ouvre ses portes au clés sous-bois
un site qui proposera les plus grandes
marques avec des réductions d'au moins
30 % où les touristes qui visitent
Versailles sont très attendu Olivier
Maniscalco Jonathan villman sont allés
faire leurs emplettes en
avant-première one nation paris c'est
parti le complexe géant de magasin de
marque de luxe à pris réduit ouvre enfin
ses portes aux clés sous-bois c'est pour
l'instant 80 boutiques qui accueilleront
le public parmi elles une firme
française de textile s'attend déjà à un
franc succès one nation représente quand
même un produit un centre très
qualitatif sur lesquels beaucoup
d'espoirs sont fondés en magasin d'usine
on est 30 % moins cher que les prix
pratiqués en boutique c'est la moyenne
donc on sait que les gens sont très
attentifs en ce moment à tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est prix donc je pense que
ça peut être ça peut avoir un très très
B impact 14 les prix discount seront
donc un atout indéniable mais les
investisseurs voient plus grand étable
sur une clientèle internationale situé à
tout juste 10 minutes du château de
Versailles wation Paris va mettre en
place des navettes qui relieront
directement le palais du Roi Soleil au
complexe commercial on pense que
rapidement presque la moitié du chiffre
d'affaires sera réalisé par les
touristes notamment les touristes en
groupe qui visitent Versailles et son
château chaque année on on proposera ces
à ces groupes de touristes de de Pronger
leur journée en venant chez nous faire
ce qu'on appelle du shopping touristique
pour les 24000 m Carr du site au style
très parisien cat inv vest a déboursé
pas moins de 110 millions d'euros à
terme 112 boutiques composeront la
galerie de one nation Paris 5 millions
de visiteurs sont attendus chaque année
des investisseurs qui rient et d'autres
qui pleurent ironie du calendrier au
même moment la société amerson annoncé
la fin du même projet caré privé West à
Montini entre 1945 et 1949 le manoir de
nouval situé à andrisie était un lieu
d'accueil et de vie pour les enfants
juifs de déportter cette maison est
aujourd'hui un lieu de résidence
artistique et un spectacle de
marionnette intitulé valise d'enfance
vient de voir le jour représentation ce
soir à 20h30 au prisme à encour il Deb
et LOD
moine
André
écoute on va faire un jeu
hein tu vas te cacher
là et moi je viendrai te chercher
bientôt mais surtout André tu ne dis
jamais à personne que tu es
juif André est aujourd'hui grand-père il
n'a jamais parlé de son histoire celle
de cet enfant juif de déporté élevé dans
une maison d'enfants à Andr peu après 19
5 se passé il l'a enfermé dans une
valise valise d'enfance est une création
née d'une rencontre avec ce lieu et son
histoire c'est un gros travail autour de
la mémoire évidemment les enfants que
nous avons retrouvé sont j des
grands-parents qui ont à peu près entre
80 et 85 ans pour la plupart n'ont
jamais raconté leur histoire ni à leur
famille ni à leurs proches on avait
envie de porter de transmettre cette
histoire à un plus large public le fait
de pouvoir s'appu appuyer sur des textes
certes mais aussi sur des êtres vivants
et de communiquer avec eux de vous de
ressentir leurs émotion d'entendre ce
qu'ils nous disent et aussi ce qu'il
nous disent pas et ce travail a apporté
énormément au spectacle parce que c'est
tout tout ce qui n tout ce qui était dit
et qui n'était pas dit qui nous a permis
d'arriver vraiment au plus profond des
sentiments et apporter autant d'émotions
au spectacle et en passant par ces bias
de de souvenir d'enfant on avait la
possibilité aussi de de toucher les les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui et d'aller
justement dans l'émotion de tous les
ressentis qu'ils ont pu avoir à l'époque
et qu'ils ont encore aujourd'hui parce
que c'est une histoire même si
aujourd'hui ils ont effectivement 80 ans
euh c'est une histoire qui qui leur
revient toujours en mémoire et qu'ils ne
peuvent
oublier il y a
quelqu'un on a pris en en compte
que c'était des souvenirs d'enfant et
donc notre personnage principal André
est une espèce de collage toutes les
histoires que nous avons recueilllies et
et et tout le spectacle est est vu par
l'œil d'un enfant il y a cette notion
aussi auquel on est très attaché de de
de ne pas tomber dans le Patos de pas
tomber dans le tragique d'avoir aussi
des moments de de légèreté malgré tout
et et donc on a aussi cette attention
sur le l'interprétation que ce soit des
marionnettes ou de notre présence donc
voilà il y a il y a toujours un travail
sur le fond sur l'écriture sur le sens
et de retrouver la la pudeur qui nous a
été transmise la marionnette crée une
distance et euh elle est un outil aussi
comme un autre pour faire passer des
émotions quand on joue avec elle la
marionnette est un un partenaire
formidable parce qu'on ne sait jamais
comment elle vaelle va nous répondre
alors que c'est nous qui l'animons et il
y a cette étrangeté et cette cette féie
qui est qui est étonnante
une création visuelle et musicale
rassemblant toutes les générations des 8
ans voilà pour ce spectacle à découvrir
mardi soir donc et puis au même moment
une projection débat d'un documentaire
consacré à Pierre rabille au nom de la
Terre aura lieu au cinéma Les Yeux
d'Elsa à saint-cir l'école en présence
du paysan écrivain et penseur l'un des
pionniers de l'agroécologie en France il
a fondé en
1994 l'association Terre et Humanisme et
il veut favoriser l'éclosion de nouveaux
modèles de société fondée sur
l'autonomie l'écologie et donc
l'humanisme c'est mardi soir à 20h30 aux
yeux d'Elsa de sincir l'école Noël ce
sera le 24 décembre mai le Père Noël est
déjà parmi nous il vient surveiller si
les enfants sont bien sages comme vont
nous l'expliquer claire Cambier et
yoline
Torz ce weekend à La Verrière le Père
Noël n'est pas descendu de la cheminée
mais de cette tour d'immeuble logique ce
n'est pas encore Noël alors pour faire
patienter les enfants jusqu'au 25
décembre il est allé à leur rencontre
avec son panier de bonbon je descend
tous les tous les ans de de là haut êes
attendu là oui là je suis attendu
ouis succès garanti petits et grands
quand de son nom et piétine d'impatience
j'attends à qu'il vienne pour mettre des
bonbons là tu es sûr que tu vas avoir
des bonbons
oui j'ai éta bien en tout cas pour
satisfaire tout le monde le Père Noël a
même dû faire appel à son assistant
parmi la foule des enfants mais aussi
des parents et même notre journaliste
yolè Torres qui elle non plus n'a pas su
résister mes bonbons moi aussi ou pas
oui oui c'est vrai je le mérite oui
mérite super toi aussi tu as ét sage à
l'école le Père Noël a fini sa tournée
dans le centreville tel une star il a
multiplié les poses photos et les
rencontres avec son public et il pense
savoir d'où vient ce succès c'est un
look à entretenir ou beaucoup de travail
c'est bon pas si facile la vie de père
Noël et toujours la barbe soyeuse ce
Père Noël c'était bien à mort pas en
tout cas se dérouler cette opération
mais ne vous inquiétez pas il passera
prochainement par la verrière toujours à
propos de Noël vous avez jusqu'au 13
décembre si vous résidez cette fois-ci à
coignère pour vous inscrire au concours
de décoration 15e édition de cet
événement Père Noël Ren lutin guirlande
certains sont d'ailleurs vous le voyez
déjà très inspiré le jury passera durant
la 2uxe quinzaine de décembre des
invitations à dîner dans les restaurant
de la ville et des bouteilles de
champagne sont à gagner deux résultats
c'est du sport à présent avant de
refermer ce journal 5e victoire de la
saison 35 à 25 à rein ce weekend pour
les moins de 18 ans du plaisir handball
les jeunes joueurs d'Alexandre taffer
sont désormais assurés de finir parmi
les trois premiers de leur pouolle et
ont donc validé leur qualification pour
la phase finale du championnat de France
de leur catégorie ils font partie des 50
meilleures équipes du pays et puis le
navigateur versaillais Tangui de la mode
qui a donc rejoint le Brésil ce weekend
arriv de la 11e édition de la transate
Jacques Vabre il était avec son
compagnon de route le comédien François
Damiens pour cette embardé sur pour
cette pour ce périple pardon sur sur la
mer ils sont arrivés les skippperss
d'initiative cœur 8e dans la catégorie
imoka 9U petites secondes devant team
plastique d'Alexandro di Benetto et
Alberto Monaco une première dans
l'histoire des courses au large ils ont
apprécié leur arrivée vous le voyez hein
Tangui de la mode qui navigue au profit
de messena Chirurgie Cardiaque son
épopée sur la transate a permis de
récolter 69000 € grâce au clic des
internautes et donc d'opérer cinq
enfants atteints de malformation
cardiaque et issu de pays
défavorisés le journal qui revient donc
demain 18h toujours en direct excellente
soirée sur notre
antenne